so when will lockdown come to an end
well the short answer is it really
depends on when the politicians
decide but what we can do is look back
at the data from the last lockdown
and see where that was when it was
phased out so let's have a look at this
number in particular the reproduction
rate you probably remember this
anything above one suggests the spread
of the disease is accelerating anything
below one
suggests it's decelerating and there's
good news here it is starting to come
down in fact the latest data suggesting
it's down to 0.7 to 1 below 1 of course
at a median of about 0.85 but how does
that compare
with last spring when we were all
focusing on our trying to work
out whether it meant the lockdown would
come to an end well what we've got here
is each of those
different lockdown so look down one look
down two and where we're at then lock
down three over there
and let's compare where we were at june
the first when primary schools reopened
where was r it was around
eight so 0.7 to 0.9 a bit lower
than where we are now but not all that
much lower but it's worth saying that
lock down the end of the lockdown was
phased so it was more than a month
from that until pubs reopened about
fourth of july that pubs
reopened r was still 0.8 so where it is
kind of more or less a little bit below
where it is now but have been there for
quite some
time that's not the only measure we can
also look at the positivity rate so the
percentage of the population testing
positive
for covert 19. this this is from the ons
the office of national statistics they
bring this out
every week and it shows you look we'll
do the same exercise again
back in july the 4th of july 0.03
of the population we're testing positive
compared with well you can see it's a
lot higher
at the moment 1.55 at the moment testing
positive so we're a long way off on that
measure needs to come down
a lot more but that's not the only way
of looking at this we could also look at
hospital admissions
key thing for getting a sense of this
disease same thing again let's have a
look back
on the fourth of july hospital
admissions back then it was 200.
right now well you can see look it's a
lot higher over 2000
at the latest but it is worth saying you
know the news might be a bit better
because it could bother because of the
vaccine
these lines come down even faster so
if that proves to be the case we will
bring that to you as soon as the data
is suggesting it